shoutout to Matt out to man here here we
were messaging on patreon and there's a
line he said here I always enjoyed your
content and I thought it was time to
become a patron wandering a pledge more
so hopefully I can a few months after
the move on making I said to him dude if
you don't pledge more I'm going to kick
your ass yeah I said I'm gonna make you
full of fear Matt beers all about quota
it's all about your Matt beer yeah dude
you're a poet I know I wanted it out I
know it
what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alba here and it's John Humphrey over
here so we're going to watch the fate of
the furious honest trailer today oh boy
that's a root fold yeah family my
favorite franchise of all time you were
just saying this movie you want to show
you so many was there's going to be a
patron of the day shout out right after
the reaction that's beer beer fairly new
patreon over there so Matt beer keep a
lookout for your shoutout yeah the
inventor of beer just followed so what's
your Excuse
[Music]
after Fast Five turned the street racing
franchise into a globe-trotting action
blockbuster yet fast six and seven
coasted of its momentum to the newest
combination of f words and numbers is
here and are still humming up at this
one fuse fate of the Furious wow these
are getting really forced welcome
alkamag availing come to expect from the
fast chives cars not cars
he just carjacked a something family and
Vin Diesel bubble growls a twosome a
boundary line in a sequel that really
overestimates how much you remember from
the last three yeah yeah well how long
does it princess and huh I did wage Oh
Hans it was in these here for cars and
but in no particular order
don't overthink this guys I had when
some of these fans will drain the
government won't do anything about it
because this guy said so US government
cannot sanction this operation in any
way now they're sending in a gang of
petty thieves and street racers to get
it back who became elite special forces
so gradually you never stop or think
about it
your car jackers when did you turn into
John wick joy Tyrese Ludacris Kurt
Russell and other characters who you
refer to by their actors names as they
fit into the background of a buddy
action comedy starring Jason Statham and
the rock - hahahahaha third side of the
law responsible for every cool scene in
the movie and struggling not to get into
their raw animal lust for each other
oh no God I got let it go I am so in for
the spit off when you're done having fun
spend lots of time sitting on an
airplane with the only guy who still
takes these films - ha ha ha ha ha
absolutely rips from live action cartoon
where this happens just see how this
grown-up sevens communicators he's
literally turned his back on his family
and walked into a different much more
boring movie with Charlize Theron she
cipher a hacker who should really fire
her assistant my assistant actually came
up with the hair she just kind of out of
nowhere said did she doing dead well
when she's not talking to her computer
screen ain't down when I minister to
she's whispering painful structure
these actually as the rockin bindi sent
almost your screen time I sort of cross
paths in voiceover the Dom uh-huh in the
distant background or in edits that make
it seem like VIN wasn't the candy-ass
male co-star the rock called out on
Instagram come on guys watch the beat so
much in common like well you both hate
fleas oh well we'll always have Brazil
this is what I do so that amazed
installment of the franchise that's
still chugging along no matter how much
that co-stars ate each other how much
the women are sidelined or how clearly
they're trying to fill tall walkers
shoes with this dingus just turn your
brain off and watch the cars go boo
because they're counting on you can
never ask for anything more
you guys want to see time you slide a
spaceship in the next one or not rule
number one know your audience
salary the following car puns just as
tired go identification number diesel
flashing mortgages flames Dwayne's in
Pawhuska lady or unready tie race looks
a ludic watch
Carlie they're on her broken Helen rear
view mirror and a new Paul's drag race
car Wawa ever so date the last Jennifer
they've supported a tall strong one and
I've always appreciated that about you
Michelle are you okay are you being held
against your will
well I guess if you want us to call the
police okay hook on the Gauss hey screen
junkies ever wondered what Planet of the
Apes Caesar would be like in today's
world with the tender file like teens to
early 20s but like lone swings in the
woods see what our audition and with any
circus Woody Harrelson and the cast and
director of war for the Planet of the
Apes and our latest honest interview
I look like Dante those correctly does
whatever spider pig does hello I'm a
hobbit and my game it's Bilbo Baggins
played in Lincoln Park with Lincoln Park
watching Lincoln bar the Lincoln watt
power comes a great reboot and the award
the best we play goes to transformers
the last night
that's just falsehood that's not true
man oh man was that a great
representation my favorite thing they
pointed out that I don't think we've
ever point in any of our fast and
furious talks is about how these
franchises kind of rely on you to
remember characters from prior
installments as if the storyline is
super important because yeah maybe do a
test start off like the storyline is
important and then they quickly don't
become important for the next two hours
and yeah then they go chase a new thing
for a while and then just make the set
PDF huge yeah yeah if that did happen a
few times when I was watching it as I've
seen every single one of these movies I
would see carrots I'd be like yeah I
watched fast whatever the seventh movie
is called like the week we saw say to
the Furious and even during pain I was
like way way back that's right yeah I
was in that guy with an inches just
munch I'm on ha I'm on I'm on hunting
yeah yeah and I completely forgot it had
any eye to this day I remember what his
role was in 6 or 7 I don't know which
one he was in you know he's a guy I
wasn't seven hit the point yeah a
helicopter the ads yeah he's chasing
after that odd or some god III die I
he's yeah he's a official bad guy some
kind I'm surprised it in touch on at all
how Jason Statham becomes a member of
the family
yeah actually I'm surprised too got that
like that after he killed Han I was
really some really surprised they did
not touch on that and shut this for hot
does this were hard that is that they
think for me that's that's a problem
with the film them like burger franchise
that occasionally really gives a damn
about its storyline and about it Emlyn
about a family and family values and I
didn't notice until people pointed out
to me later that Vin Diesel and doing
Johnson don't share screen time together
this movie I remember that feud going on
I thought it was just a publicity stunt
but then after watching the movie and
seeing how they don't really share
screen time ever yeah that's that that I
forgot all about her I didn't realize
until they added it out here I wonder
how these how had worked it out in the
production because like that's got to be
hard having two of your main stars and
also the main parts now at least a
family like aunt
apparently stand each other like ads I
feel like that spells trouble for this
serial going forward I mean honestly man
I was just telling you like what three
days ago about that we're just in the
car I just said to you like see I'm just
so sick of The Fast and the Furious
franchise
I even like fate of the Furious I
technically fall under the spectrum of
liking it but I'm tired of it I'm sick
of it I'm like you know man you gotta
wrap these yeah wrap this franchise up
because I feel like they don't really
have anything new to offer than more
ridiculousness and it's like she has the
genre again yeah I'm in a big way and
what are they going to do as I can I
don't care enough about the storyline or
the characters that they rely on you to
like kind of remember yeah I don't think
they're allowing you to care about I
thing to rely on you remember it yeah
yeah just remember that of the different
more convoluted it gets the better track
you cam yeah you know and John Bailey
texted me and I thought I forgot texting
back I should do that thank you
he told me he lives down the street from
me now dude you should be here in this
reaction here in this react you should
be reacting in his honest reliable own
jokes
yeah oppression for a wrap of the video
at John there was something I have to do
that's right shout out to Matt up to man
you're here fairly new patreon over
there do you think Matt beers his real
name
I don't know I'm wondering that since I
saw it I don't think beers his real name
who the hell last name is beer the
inventor of beer done everything
anything that all going as the lineage
isset admire bastards she and I have
mastered the art of brewing what I said
to him was honestly dude no pressure to
do that we really appreciate whatever
you're currently contributing and I just
want you to know now that your shadow
does here that is a lot yeah it's all
the core of the pledge money that we
only
do this for money in fact we hate this
we hate this it's still a map here by
the way subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bells subscribe
it's green junkies dad John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house comm course
through patreon we've got shirt shop out
Spreadshirt Khan slash the real reach up
and we're gonna go we're gonna watch all
the oak studio Doyle right now got a
long day Neill Blomkamp a fire and all
going up mañana this is people look out
for that like you're a boat dead long
she